[Music]
hey you guys Sunday here we are with a
sidetrack because I was actually gonna
put up a matinee today but I put it up
yesterday instead the one about the
house in between that paranormal
documentary so I said well we'll just do
a sidetrack today and so that's what
we're doing yeah we saw that [ __ ] up
movie last night Cannibal Holocaust
cannonball I had seen it a long time ago
but I didn't really remember all that
much about it it was on jo Bob slashed
driving because I was like I always look
like on shudder like every week to see
what he's up to and well you know this
was kind of unprecedented but he
actually did you know his regular thing
where they show the movie and then he
comes in every now and then it talks
about it and they also did a separate
one where you could just watch the
commentary in case you didn't want to
watch the movie because shudder does
indeed have the uncut version that has
all the animal killing yeah in it yeah I
didn't like it I didn't like I liked it
at first yeah I thought to set up to the
movie is like okay because it's really
kind of two different movie yeah like a
movie within a movie yeah and then
seemed okay but then there's like
eventually guest star part where dude
had just what kind of animal was that
look like a little possum yeah it was
some kind of I think it's a quwata
mundane quwata Mundi he's got this thing
like that just takes a damn skewer and
just skewers it through the neck and
blood goes flying out into things
[ __ ] like and that didn't kill it so
he did it again on the other side and I
was like man [ __ ] this movie you didn't
even see the turtle or yeah I don't want
to for the monkey or the page yeah after
that I was just kind of like I was
looking at my tablet and I'd look up and
see what was going on but I didn't want
to see any any [ __ ] you know I mean I
said it a million times in case you guys
don't know the show I'm a hunter and I
mouth killed animals but I believe in
swift clean kills and that's not what
they were doing here man has animal
torture and they did that [ __ ] on
purpose they were trying to be shocking
shocking but I'll be good expensive
[ __ ] animals you know man I mean and
they said oh well we did eat them
afterward and stuff like that which you
know fine but it's like still now some
might say well wild animals eat each
other
alive it's worse than that you know when
when one animals which I guess you could
kind of say that but a human is not in
that cycle you know talking about we're
kind of above that we have the
technology to do a swift clean kill on
an animal so it doesn't suffer the
annamund so that it kind of
differentiates us from other predators
you know you know the only reason why of
animals are doing that is because they
don't have a choice all they have is
claws and teeth yeah but though you know
some of the cleanest kills I've ever
seen we're from [ __ ] like lions and big
cats because all they do is just grab
the animal by the throat wants to have
it and just choke it out well because
they don't want to get her because the
you know they're prey animals have sharp
who's and sometimes horns and things
like that so it's like they don't want
to get hurt either because if they get
hurt then they'll starve yeah so it's
it's in their best interest to have
evolved to make it pretty cool make it
very quick so that the animal isn't
struggling and they'll you know you'll
see parts where a big cattle grab a
zebra you know by the back legs or by
the by the by the of the rump and the
claws go in its child you know it
stretches the skin out a little bit but
it's just trying to stop the damn animal
yeah and get on top of it but that
animal is so filled with adrenaline that
it doesn't feel any pain from that yet I
mean there are some animals that will
eat other animals alive fish you know
they do it a lot but fish are pretty
[ __ ] permit if they have a primitive
nervous system they're more like robots
I was always upset by like sharks and
and killer whales like eating seals yeah
cuz the seal I mean seals are alone man
yeah but this is just the way nature is
nature is not oh I know nice you know I
mean but humans are supposed to you know
be better it would be nice if we would
could be yeah tortured animals yeah you
know if you're gonna eat it so you know
so it's like I did watch it like I said
I watched it a long time ago and I've
seen like a lot of the old [ __ ] up cuz
this was kind of like in the same vein
as like you know mando Connie and stuff
like that which had that kind of [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in it too um
so you know I watch it but it's like you
know it didn't really feel that good
about it it's like you know and by
comparison
you know the humans that get killed in
it you know the gang rapes and the
beheadings and them eating the people
and stuff it looks pretty good like for
you know found-footage and you know it
looks kind of realistic and stuff but it
didn't upset me mostly because the you
know the characters are such [ __ ]
that you're like yeah I eat them to me
it was obvious that the human stuff was
fake yeah in 1980 you know the effects
were good enough that you know Ruggero
Deodato obviously which most people that
are in the horror movies know like he
actually got dragged into court and he
had to like produce the actors and stuff
because they thought he killed him they
thought it was a snuff film yet and they
thought that he killed him for real I
mean like I said some of the effects are
really good particularly that one the
girl that's like impaled on the on the
stick that's like on a lot of the
posters and stuff I mean that looks
really really good
I'm glad I didn't see the monkey
evidently they damn top of the monkeys
head off why it's alive and the brain of
it now that would really pissed me off
like I didn't see it I didn't know until
I first yeah you were at cuz you missed
like I said you missed the turtle and
that was really really yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] Italy came after him behind all
that they weren't into that animal
cruelty they would they he got in
trouble for get in trouble for that see
he got what he wanted he got famous got
a lot of attention but well yeah and
it's still like one of the most infamous
you know gore films ever you know just
because it's been banned in 70s which is
weird you had Italy prosecuted him but
he was out of their jurisdiction he
didn't do it in Italy he did it and
where Columbia they shot it in Columbia
yeah so I think they I think they had a
drop check charges huh on that didn't it
sure how that worked and it changed it
they changed it to something else having
to do with an anti bullfighting law yeah
that's right Vikram with that yeah which
you know fair enough
like I said it's you know it's it's I'm
not saying everyone should see it but
it's like horror fans should be like
aware of it and like yeah you don't have
to watch it if you don't want then I'll
blame you if you don't want to watch it
because I don't even like watching
movies with like fake animal things I
don't give a [ __ ] you can kill the
people you want in movies I don't care
but the second you like do something
[ __ ] up to like a cat or a dog or
something yeah I'm out of there it could
have been a good movie yeah it's just it
had a bunch of unnecessary animal
torture yeah in it like I said there we
didn't actually need that fur they were
trying to go for like a um
mondo Connie or yeah like later like
faces of death and stuff like that I
think you phases of death came out those
ones came out later but yeah I just I
was all kind of the same I just thought
it was like unnecessary and tacky yeah
it kind of made the kind of belittled
the movie he should have left all the
animal stuff out yeah cuz you could just
just fortune the humans yeah because you
know that's fake it's fake yeah and like
I said the people were [ __ ] so you
know what I mean
well character characters the characters
were [ __ ] that's what I meant yeah
so it's like you didn't really care if
they [ __ ] got eaten or whatever yeah
a lot of a lot of the people that
actually did the killings of the animals
was when I was an Italian farm boy he
was in it and the Indians yeah they got
real Indians in it
yes South America locals I mean David
they weren't like from they weren't from
tribes or anything like that they were
from like the city yeah just local
people dressed not looking but they
dressed him up like quote/unquote
savages yeah Adam run around yeah but
then you find out that the Italians are
savages too well yeah that was kind of
the whole point that he brought to make
with the movie was that you know the the
people that came there like this film
crew were just as shitty or shittier
actually because you know they weren't
even like killing the animals for food
or for punishment or anything like that
they were just [ __ ] with him yeah
well they could [ __ ] with him other
than other than the animal scenes I
thought the rest of it just looked like
typical Italian b-movie stuff I mean to
be honest this first part works I heard
of it um you know the part that's not
the found footage yeah the setup was
good it's good and it's actually like
really well done cuz like I said they
even went to the trouble of filming like
the first part of it on 35-millimeter
and the second part in 16 millimeter so
it would look like like a differentiated
like this looks shitty er because this
was like the this crappy footage that
they shot so they did actually
because I don't know if like you kids
know today and you think Blair Witch
Project was the first found-footage but
actually Cannibal Holocaust the first
found footage movie as far as I know it
wasn't the first cannibal movie I think
that was man from deep river but um you
know or at least the first one of that
cycle but I'm pretty sure it was the
first foul play yeah the set up had a
pretty good character in it it was kind
of like kind of like something out of
predator you had this black dude who's
like a he's like a captain of a [ __ ]
commando unit and he's got these
Colombian soldiers underneath him and he
knows everything about the damn Indians
and you know talk about this tribal war
that was going on and I just I just
liked that part he you know the [ __ ]
head cool weapon says thirty carbines
and a [ __ ] mini Aussies [ __ ] and it
just I just thought the guy was kind of
a believable character he speaking a
couple different languages he supposed
he spoke Spanish and English and then he
speak some French I can't remember maybe
but he was like a character out of
[ __ ] predator yeah I don't know who
that guy was but he would have been
right on he looked familiar you might
have been in some other Italian movies
from the time period I'd have to look it
up my camera what his name was um I
should say to that like not only was the
animal stuff real but also the footage
that they showed of like the people like
getting like with hoods being put over
their head and assassinated and stuff
that they showed like oh this is the
film crew that disappeared this was
their first documentary that they were
working on that footage was real like
all those people that have that were
getting shot and you know and [ __ ] like
that was real and all the animal [ __ ]
was real but yeah like obviously all the
cannibal stuff and beheading that wasn't
yeah cuz those people did like turn back
up afterward but if you want to see a
[ __ ] up movie you can see it it's like
I said it's infamous I don't really
recommend it I don't think it's worth it
yeah Jenna I mean like I said Eli Roth
made a green inferno like as an homage
that was better actors you remember yeah
I don't know like I don't there was
something that I liked about green
inferno and then there was something I
didn't really like about it and I guess
I can't really put my finger on what it
was but you know I like Eli Roth in
general though like oh you know I I kind
of liked some of those if I'm in the
right mood I don't mind some of those
like torture porn II kind of movies like
and stuff Cannibal Holocaust is just
kind of like one of those kind of like
one of those movies he [ __ ] make you
feel dirty when you're watching it yeah
that's what it's you know well yeah like
faces well that was the intent such a
[ __ ] animal animal torture and
intervention it just just just not for
me
I could watch a version of it with that
edited out the UK version just has that
edited yeah it's pretty easy to find one
with all the animals yeah he taken out
like a lot of countries that's the only
version they'll show there's no point in
doing that [ __ ] for real yeah and I mean
Joe Bob even said because it was like a
whole bunch of like there was a whole
bunch of disclaimers like before they
showed it like before the Jim Bob show
came on and even Joe Bob himself said
that you know it's like I don't condone
like the [ __ ] animal cruelty in this
he's like I think people should get the
death penalty just for kicking a dog so
it's like this is not and I'm like yeah
I guess I can't agree with you on that
it's it was to me it was just a cheap
shot yeah by the director yeah yeah that
he just took the eat quick and easy path
killed some animals too [ __ ] gross
you out and piss you off yeah which I
just thought was tacky yeah and it
didn't really help the story it didn't
serve a story at all yeah it was just I
mean it was basically just put in there
just put in there to for extra [ __ ] that
you go like the faces of death the end
under man yeah even though a lot of the
faces of death stuff was faked by dragon
look I've only seen like the first maybe
two of them um some of the [ __ ] in there
was pretty gross and it was real and
stuff but I think a lot of the [ __ ] in
there was faked yeah I think I think 90%
of it was fake I mean all the [ __ ] was
like the car accidents and stuff I think
that was pretty real because we watched
that [ __ ] and [ __ ] driver's ed got
back in the day they would show you that
[ __ ] with like [ __ ] people get in
there and people with the damn bottom
jaw [ __ ] hanging yeah so I think the
worst one I saw I can't remember god
dammit what the hell was the name blood
and blood on a high blood on the highway
or something like that and they showed
they cuz they showed us a bunch of them
there was one where it was like an old
couple and they had driven off I guess
the guy fell asleep at the wheel or
something and I guess they drove off an
overpass and the car caught on fire so
they showed would like them taking these
crispy old people like out of this
[ __ ] car and it was like
really really disgusting I'm sure it
like smelled even worse yeah one guy
that got like his head run over that was
good I still remember that sale
that's pretty [ __ ] nasty but yeah so
another thing I wanted to mention was
that okay so the next episode that's
going up episode 198 which I guess a
spoiler alert is about Bob Lazar at
about area 51 or all that because we've
had like a bunch of requests to do that
I can't believe because I had notes and
[ __ ] like that and I thought that I had
written this down in my notes somewhere
but I didn't and then when I was going
to edit the show I was just kind of like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe I forgot to
mention that so I'm gonna mention it on
here now there was a thing where cuz you
know I mean just like a brief overview
Bob Lazar says that he used to work at
you know s forum near area 51 and he was
trying to like reverse engineer
spacecraft in blah-dee-blah
so one of the things that he used to
claim back in the day when he used to
first started making these claims like
bacon back in the late 80s early 90s was
that one of this one of the things that
I think he was kind of implying that
this was alien technology that we had
appropriated was like this hand scanner
it was like a security type scanner you
know just like they do with like the
eyeball [ __ ] nowadays but it had like a
hand thing on it and he's like yeah it
like measured your finger bones or
something cuz everyone's is different
and that's like how you got in and
everything and so he was making it seem
like this was some big like
technological big deal thing and he
talked about this on the Netflix
documentary and the guy that made the
documentary like shows a picture was
this it and he's like oh yeah I never
thought I'd see that again blah blah
blah well it turns out that even though
he made this claim in the late 80s that
this was like some you know alien
technology or some way ahead technology
they actually knew about these hand
scanners they are real they were using
them as early as 1971 and it wasn't
secret and in fact that very same hand
scanner appeared in Close Encounters of
the Third Kind whenever the [ __ ] that
came out 80 78 yeah late 70s early 80s
so I don't know I think it was that was
before Star Wars wasn't it
oh was it okay maybe it's earlier than I
thought maybe was 75 I can't read my
body for some reason I thought it was
early 80s but it's you know everything
I think it might be before Star Wars no
I can't hold it - yeah you know maybe
not yeah but so so it was well-known
enough that it was like in that movie so
it's not like it was top secret or
anything so I just thought it was very
funny
that he kind of made it seem like it was
this big secret technology perhaps we
had gotten from the aliens when it was
like well known everybody knew but in a
[ __ ] movie and they even showed it in
the movie like the [ __ ] hands get the
exact same one that he was like going oh
wow this is like what they used to have
there yeah we you could you're
confirming his story it did exist well
yeah that's probably why I told you I
told you it was real it's like yeah well
you could have seen it in the movie or
like I said everybody knew about it yeah
everybody knew about it so it's not like
it was like Topsy I'd be like saying
yeah we had these things they had the
alphabet and they were on these little
[ __ ] box you might like this
yeah it actually printed it on a piece
of paper and everyone went oh yeah oh
you mean one of these a typewriter yeah
that's it
that was some fancy aliens yeah yeah but
yeah so that's the next show that's
going up like I said if you're a patron
you'll get to see it tomorrow morning
it's a shooter in standard time other
than that you get on Tuesday I think it
came out pretty funny yeah we had a good
time with it I'll talk about aliens yeah
he wants to talk about aliens yeah and
you know I gotta do it we got to do um
Phoenix lights yeah I'm like actually
amazed that we hadn't don't think we did
Phoenix lights or mentioned it on one of
those marathon shows that we probably
did but we did it needs its own show
because there's a lot to that case yeah
that you know that the average person
doesn't consider yeah well come out over
the years if you got the flares yeah you
know we'll definitely do it like in the
next the video that they show all the
time is flares yeah but there's another
video of the damn craft that [ __ ] no
one ever [ __ ] is that they never show
because it's real low-quality
and you just see like six lights and and
it's real fuzzy and grainy because it
was taken with just a shitty VHS camera
from a distance and they try to blow it
up to look
at it and that's the craft it's just
that they never show that on television
because the the quality so bad yeah what
you know yeah and then five Simonton
said he saw it too
yeah who was the governor they didn't
say anything that's right I remember I
remember what didn't we watch like a
documentary about that or something yeah
I remember yeah late years years later
and I think I got I think like I read a
book about it a while back
years later he came out he said he saw
it too but he didn't want to same things
he didn't wanna cause a panic cuz nobody
above him gave him any information yeah
and I think it was some kind of an
extraterrestrial craft and it was more
than one of them evidently but that was
the main one alien tour group because
people were calling all over the state
as it was coming and they kind of
described different things depending on
where they were yeah what time they
called and there have been people that
try to put it together through all the
911 calls and they think it might have
been like a parade of them to where if
you looked out in the sky you can only
see one at a time but other people saw
other ones in other places and they were
so they were going like one after
another yeah they were like no today's
kind of spread out kind of like a parade
and going over the state yeah together
you know one of them is supposed to be a
big sphere that was one of them big
sphere with lights on it yeah but they
weren't trying to hide themselves I just
think it's very hard to it would be very
hard to fake that because the 911
operators said that people were calling
and the 9-1-1 operators across the state
were being called simultaneously as it
was going over the state yeah that would
be much hard to be real hard one person
right so and it was just everything was
lighting up they were all seeing it
calling 9-1-1 and the areas were all
going off at the same time in unison so
how could you coordinate people right to
do that yeah
so there was something flying yeah and
they were calling it calling about it
you know that's so you know you can you
can take that to the bank it's something
was fly
yeah and it disturbed people another
thing that I forgot to mention I think
I'm the Bob Lazar show was I totally
forgot to mention the storm area51 event
you know what I mean no oh oh that thing
where they were yeah yeah that where
somebody like started it as a joke laya
you know what I mean like hey let's all
storm area 51 um but some people yeah I
think like 3000 people turned up but
they stood in the area but they just
kind of stood there it was a joke I
think one person got arrested from going
through the fence but everybody just
kind of yeah everybody just kind of like
showed up in like costumes and yeah hung
out they weren't gonna [ __ ] go into
the area fit don't get shot they would
get shot if you get far enough in there
yep they definitely will shoot you with
it there's like certainly so there's an
in-depth defense I talked about the
roundness on the show that's coming up
he'll warn you in certain areas then
they'll arrest you in and then if you
get deeper than that they'll [ __ ]
shoot you without ya yeah cuz they have
signs all over the place right says hey
past this point we're just gonna be
trying your own bud we're not even gonna
warn you we're just gonna blow your
[ __ ] head off yeah all right so uh
was that odd that you had to talk about
first Sunday I just you just look at the
news you see what you know what
Nostradamus predicted is coming true I'm
just gonna leave it at that
I could I've wore gamed it out I've wore
gamed it out it does if this can go a
couple different ways but in the end I
for a minute it to me it almost look
like the collapse of the Soviet Union
but I don't think it'll I don't think
that that's how it's gonna go anymore
but I don't know if you guys want me to
talk about that I'll do it I'll do
another what what sidetracked about it
try to keep the [ __ ] show light and
like free from politics but you know I
mean everybody sees what's going on just
you know stay [ __ ] chilled out just
come just just watch your own ass stay
out of the way of this [ __ ] don't get
involved in this [ __ ] that's what I
tried
but you know what I mean it's kind of
like so we'll either tomorrow which is
Monday so it will either do another side
track tomorrow or we might do a matinee
depending on what we end up watching
this evening we are planning on watching
a movie like an old movie tonight for
the retrospective which I'm not going to
spoil unless you're a patron in which
case you already know because I already
posted about it um but we might do a new
one I don't know what new one we're
gonna do I think shutter has a new one
and the weird thing is like I was
looking at the rentals on YouTube for
like new horror movies and there was
like - that looks really good but then
it said 2020 but then when I looked them
up like one was from 2016 and one was
from 2017 so I don't know if it's just
because they only just got released and
that's why they've marked them as 2020
so I guess they just started streaming
and before that you couldn't really get
them so I guess that's why but um so
we'll see how that goes so um we'll see
you guys again tomorrow either a movie
review or another sidetrack so have a
good rest of your weekend
and we'll talk to you again soon
[Music]